fait manuel Chase bonjour Emmanuel vous
vous trouviez il y a quelques jours à
peaugrove ce qu'une ville située sur la
ligne de front qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire de plus sur ces attaques
et bien écoutez le bilan le bilan a
augmenté au cours de la nuit avec les
recherches qui ont repris ce matin vous
l'avez mentionné cette personne sont
mortes 67 ont été blessés dans ces
attaques car il y en a eu deux il y a eu
une première frappe qui a touché des
bâtiments résidentiels en plein cœur de
Pocket qu'un restaurant dans lequel
beaucoup de journalistes à la fois
étrangers et
ukrainien se retrouve ainsi que des
bénévoles ainsi que des soldats en
permission qui reçoivent notamment leurs
proches qui viennent leur rendre visite
tout près de la ligne de front il y a
aussi énormément de familles qui se
trouvent dans l'endroit qui a été visé
un bâtiment résidentiel avec plus de 200
personnes y habitant le bilan est très
lourd puisqu'il y a eu une deuxième
frappe dans un procédé qui est courant
ici en Ukraine lors de frappe russe il y
a une première frappe puis les forces
russes attendent que les secours se
rendent en place pour lancer une
deuxième attaque c'est ce qui s'est
passé hier à poprovsk et on compte parmi
les blessés justement 67 blessés on
compte 27 officiers de police ainsi que
7 secouristes deux enfants ont également
été blessés et parmi les sept mort il y
a le chef délégué au secours aux
pompiers de la région de doniesk qui est
décédé il avait 52 ans c'est frappent et
bien elles sont quotidiennes ici en
Ukraine la ville de pocross qui a
déclaré une journée de deuil c'est
aujourd'hui mais l'ensemble de la
population
ukrainienne est très affectée par
chacune de ces frappes cette un nouveau
traumatisme qui s'ajoute après un an et
demi de guerre totale de la Russie
contre l'Ukraine
merci Emmanuel chasse pour toutes ces
précisions